hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my arrow season for mr. terrific
video the show has cast Michael Holt so
I'm gonna explain his history in the
comics and how the show might adapt him
that they're probably to change a few
minor things this is going to be
something of an origin story for his
character just like the show is kind of
a prequel for Justice League in terms of
Oliver's level of development it's the
same thing for all the other comic book
characters that they bring on with like
the one exception maybe being Vandal
Savage just because he's immortal
so he became like the Vandal Savage he
is today a long long time ago so mr.
terrific mostly you guys are probably at
least a little bit familiar with the
character you may have seen him in the
animated TV shows you may have seen him
in the comics he's been in both Justice
League and Justice Society of America
mostly just the Society and he's
actually he's actually the second person
to be named mr. terrific Michael Holt
like the character that were going to be
seeing as mr. terrific only took the
name in the comics after he met the
spectre in the spectre told him about
the life story of Terry Salone the first
mr. terrific
Michael Holt became so inspired that he
took the name as his own the jacket that
he wears with fair play on the sleeves
is an homage to the Terry Sloan
character the story behind fair play is
that Terry Sloan in the Golden Age
comics he was he was like the Golden Age
mr. terrific he created the Fair Play
Club to combat juvenile delinquency as
in you should play fairly so modern
mister terrific where's that it's a no
Majin it's kind of a meta thing because
it you know he fights villains all the
time play fair villains come on Errol is
a show does a really good job of turning
things like this into Easter eggs with
turns of phrase or like you know like an
offhanded joke so don't be surprised if
you hear Michael Holt on the show or
felicity because he a lot of his scenes
are going to be with felicity makeup
fair play joke but I'm not expecting him
to roll in to arrow season for wearing a
jacket that says Fair Play
even though arrow has started to embrace
magic and a lot of other outlandish
things they still try to stay pretty
practical it's still something of a
crime drama show if you're not familiar
with his powers he essentially he has
the ability to learn very fast he could
pick up new skills on a dime like he'll
learn really complicated surgery he can
learn machines really any any complex
idea that he thinks about he just
automatically absorbs he does possess
like a certain level of technological
cloaking like he calls himself invisible
to all technology in the mask that he
wears the the t ohan his face is that
they're actually nanites bonded to his
skin that are part of the costume but
also aid in cloaking him his signature
technology are the t spheres so I'm
hoping that they let him create those on
arrow over the course of the season the
atom got to build his suit and he got to
shrink by the season finale so mr.
terrific probably going to make the T
Sphere sometime during the year they're
basically just like small robots that
ate him they have their own weaponry
defense systems and they can carry him
around like he can fly using them they
bear his weight so they're kind of like
a bunch of swiss army robots on top of
all that stuff he's also a gold medal
winning Olympic decathlete but remember
he learns things almost instantly and in
that includes physical things that he
learns so he's also a really badass
martial artist the way he describes it
in the comics is that he has a natural
aptitude for natural aptitudes so I'm
really excited to see arrow play with
that like if he's going to be working
with felicity at Palmer tech then expect
him to out Felicity felicity because
that's kind of Felicity's deal being
like the smartest person in the room he
did have his own solo title in the new
52 universe for a little while but but
it didn't sell very well so DC canceled
it if you want to read like a really
good mr. terrific storyline just start
with the new 52 stuff they've already
collected most of it in trade paperbacks
it's called mr. terrific mind games some
of the really good deep cuts though are
JLA JSA secret files and origins number
one he goes to the Batcave using using a
pretense but he really wants to talk to
Batman about his grief in losing his
wife and child the TV show is turning
him into an LGBT character so I don't
know how they're gonna deal with his
wife and child from the comics in the
continuity of the TV show he may have
just had someone really close to him
dial like a boyfriend or a husband or a
brother or sister he did have a mentally
challenged older brother in the comics
that died when he was 15 so they might
use that as proxy for his grief I'm not
expecting the show to deal with the
religious aspects of the character like
a big part of his character in the
comics you know for better or worse is
that he's an atheist despite the fact
that the spectre is responsible for him
taking the name mr. terrific the spectre
is literally God's spirit of vengeance
so if God exists then how can you be an
atheist so it's like it's a big
contradiction
think arrows just going to sidestep that
and remember there are a bunch of new
characters coming on to arrow this
season I'm expected to see Michael Holt
about as much as we saw Ray Palmer
during arrow season 3 and yes
the atom is going to be part of arrow
season 4 like we'll probably see him in
the premiere they have to follow up on
what happened to him in the finale I
know people were a little confused as to
what happened he just he shrunk down
accidentally he did he didn't know what
happened so he might be teeny tiny in
episode 1 but for the most part Ray
Palmer is going to legends of tomorrow
the legends characters will appear on
the flash and arrow during the first
half of the season they'll set them up
for the spin-off but not as much as we
saw in season 4 probably most of the
first half of the season is going to be
dedicated to introducing the new
characters like damian darhk-- anarchy
who's also one of the new villains they
also just announced Baron blitzkrieg is
coming on the show he's going to be a
flashback villain though if you're not
familiar with him he's a Vandal Savage
collaborator from from way way back in
the comics so I think that they're gonna
change his character a lot for the show
do not expect a whole lot of Nazi stuff
on arrow hail Hydra here's my big
question for you guys what are you
hoping to see from mr. terrific on arrow
considering most of his scenes will be
with felicity I feel like everyone just
wants to see T spheres and the T on the
face I don't think will get the T on the
face definitely t spheres though it
would be criminal for them not to do
that from a CG perspective you know if
they can do Gorilla Grodd I feel like T
spheres would be pretty easy
they did say Comic Con that he would be
joining the show in Episode two so we
won't have to wait long to meet him I
guess that means Oliver and Felicity's
vacation or whatever they've been doing
for the last couple of months is going
to be over by episode two because if
felicity is going to be working with
them and remember going to meet him then
she'll have to be back in the city
somewhere the actor that they cast is
echo Callum I'm not super familiar with
a lot of his work but he's the comedian
he's done stuff with The Groundlings
Upright Citizens Brigade
so we'll see I feel like they cast him
to fit with Felicity's tone you know
she's just a lot of the comedy on the
show flows from her so it makes sense
they would try to cast a comedian in the
role somebody who can do the superhero
drama stuff but can also riff on a dime
I feel like sometimes some of the best
actors come from comedy backgrounds
because they're so good at improvisation
Stephen Amell has actually said that
working with John Barrowman is really
like opened his mind from an acting
perspective just just because John
Barrowman has
like a broad background a good example
of that on the flash is Tom Cavanaugh
like he's probably like the best actor
on the flash which is why he's probably
going to be the villain again it just
feels right that the best actor on a
superhero show gets to be the villain
just because villains tend to be the
most complicated characters you guys can
let me know if you agree but like look
at the Avengers for instance like who do
you think is the best actor do you feel
like Tom Hiddleston is like the best
actor from that group of people maybe
not the best leading man but I do I do
feel like he could act circles around
Chris Hemsworth speaking of villains
though I just did a Gotham video about a
bunch of the new villains that they're
bringing on it's going to be like the
rise of the villains although Michael
Chiklis is the answer to that he's going
to be the new police captain on Gotham
season to give me all of your Gotham
clobberin time jokes I think for my next
video i might do a Suicide Squad Jason
Todd video and just do like a history of
all the Robins in the comics off the top
of my head I think there's like 11 or 12
different Robins from the comics so be
sure to subscribe to get everything if
there's any like arrow or flash bonus
videos that you guys want just let me
know in the comments just in case you
guys haven't seen it yet you can click
here for that Gotham season 2 preview
and you can click here to learn all
about the flash season 2 in the some of
the upgrades they're making to the suit
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight